[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazing donde les presentamos los
acontecimientos más destacados del
continente africano Mi nombre es Y estos
son los titulares los nigerianos llevan
días Esperando saber quién dirigirá su
país la comisión electoral independiente
ha anunciado los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales los detalles
en un momento
un año Rusia invadió a Ucrania y
desencadenó un conflicto que cambió el
equilibrio geoeconómico mundial en esta
edición analizamos como el continente
africano ha afrontado las consecuencias
de esta guerra en términos económicos
la situación es muy preocupante en Tunes
para los migrantes subsaharianos tras
declaraciones del presidente
quien denunció su presencia en el país
como un complot para cambiar la
composición demográfica de túnez los
migrantes ya no se atreven a salir a las
calles por miedo a las represalias tanto
de la policía como de la población
los nigerianos llevan días esperando los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales y el nombre del que
dirigiera su país la comisión electoral
independiente ha anunciado el ganador de
esta sirenidas elecciones presidenciales
veamos
con la danza de la Victoria vol
latinobus celebró El Triunfo como nuevo
presidente de Nigeria el candidato del
partido gobernante congreso de todos los
progresistas y antiguos gobernador de
lagos obtuvo 8,79 millones de votos por
encima de los 6,98 millones del
principal rival de la oposición a Tico a
bubacar y los 6,1 millones de votos de
Peter Ovi la opción más popular entre
los jóvenes y quien se había consagrado
como el candidato sorpresa que tenía la
esperanza de superar las opciones
tradicionales en su discurso de Victoria
tiene muy llamado a la unidad
Este es un momento brillante en la vida
de cualquier hombre y de corazón les
digo Muchas gracias También aprovecho
esta oportunidad para invitar a mis
compañeros competidores para que nos
dejen formar equipo juntos es la única
nación que tenemos es un país que
debemos construir juntos ganamos juntos
para unir piezas rotas debemos trabajar
por la unidad la felicidad y la armonía
la oposición rechazó los resultados y
señaló el nuevo método tecnológico de
recolección de datos como el culpable de
un proceso lleno de dificultades
técnicas la entidad electoral había
prometido subir los resultados de cada
unidad de votación en su sitio web en
tiempo real pero la mayoría de unidades
no pudo hacerlo lo que dificultó la
confianza en el proceso varios políticos
y ciudadanos pidieron la renuncia del
presidente de la comisión electoral
nacional independiente y la anulación
del resultado
discípulos nigerianos tuvieron que
esperar casi cuatro días para obtener
resultados desde el sábado algunos
ciudadanos decidieron custodiar sus
votos y en varias regiones del país
grupos de personas en su mayoría jóvenes
se quedaron hasta altas horas de la
noche iluminando con sus teléfonos
celulares el proceso de conteo con
antecedentes de fraude y violencia
durante las jornadas electorales un año
después de la invasión rusa a Ucrania
las consecuencias se han sentido en
todos los continentes y el orden mundial
se ha sacudido en África el conflicto
afectó a las economías de los países con
tasas de inflación Récord precios de
energía disparados y recesión económica
Aunque en general los países africanos
han podido mostrar una cierta capacidad
de resiliencia los efectos adversos de
esta guerra son claramente visibles en
el siguiente informe repasamos las
consecuencias económicas de este
conflicto en el continente
en África las consecuencias del
conflicto ruso ucraniano se han sumado a
las de la crisis del covid 19 antes de
la pandemia África era el continente de
crecimiento económico más rápido del
mundo la Guerra de Ucrania que comenzó
justo cuando las economías empezaban a
recuperarse a estancado el desarrollo y
la reconstrucción económica según el
banco africano de desarrollo el
crecimiento medio del producto interno
bruto en el Continente caso del 4.8% en
2021 al 3.8% en 2022 el nivel de
comercio entre África y Rusia y Ucrania
es moderado Pero algunas naciones
africanas dependen en gran medida de
estos dos países para importaciones como
las de los granos en 2020 por ejemplo
los países africanos importaron el
equivalente a 4.000 millones de dólares
en productos agrícolas de Rusia y 2900
millones de Ucrania según datos de la
conferencia de las Naciones Unidas sobre
comercio y desarrollo Rusia y Ucrania
suministran el 32 y el 12%
respectivamente de las necesidades de
trigo del continente en promedio en todo
el continente el precio del maíz ha
aumentado un 80%. el de la harina un 50%
el del arroz un 40%, el del aceite un
37% el de las aves un 30% y el de las
naranjas un 20% Mientras que el de los
tomates un 10% la directora del fondo
monetario internacional admitió que el
continente está pagando el precio de la
guerra en Ucrania
hemos identificado a 48 países
especialmente afectados por la
inseguridad alimentaria
Security yo le sorprenderá que un gran
número de ellos estén en el África
subsahariana África en cuanto a los
precios de la energía su aumento ha
hecho temer lo peor en 2022
Aunque la situación parece haberse
estabilizado en 2023 con la fijación por
el g7 del precio máximo del crudo en 60
dólares por barril nada es inamovible ya
que es probable que este precio cambie
en función de la evolución del mercado
según el Banco Mundial los diversos
choques inflacionarios se prolongarán en
el Continente al menos hasta 2024 tanto
en el frente alimentario como en el
energético con picos nunca vistos desde
la crisis del petróleo de 1973
en túnez el presidente
hizo unas declaraciones que
escandalizaron algunos tunecinos y a sus
vecinos según el jefe de estado la
presencia de migrantes subsaharianos en
el territorio tunecino forma parte de un
complot para cambiar la composición
demográfica de la nación Nora africana y
alejarla de su identidad árabe musulmana
las declaraciones del jefe de estado han
agravado el de terror contra los
migrantes subsaharianos que ya
experimentan la brutalidad policial y
todo tipo de agresiones verbales y
incluso físicas por parte de la
población ahora muchos de ellos temen
por su vida y ya no se atreven a salir a
las calles las organizaciones tunecinas
de defensa de los derechos humanos han
denunciado las declaraciones de el clima
de xenofobia que reina en el país
mientras que la unión africana también
ha emitido un comunicado condenando las
declaraciones del presidente tunecino
para hablar de la situación en túnez
estamos con sadía
activista anti racista tunecina sabía
bienvenida África 7 días en primer lugar
En qué estado se encuentran los
migrantes con los que ha podido hablar
el estado psicológico Es realmente
deplorable deplorable y creo que van a
necesitar una ayuda psicológica Que
obviamente no van a conseguir tienen
miedo están asustados
cada vez que oigo que alguien se acerca
a mi puerta cada vez que oigo casos cada
vez que oigo que alguien Llama a mi
puerta tengo miedo de que me dé un
vuelco el corazón se trata de una mujer
subsahariana con hijos en casa
Y por qué cree que el presidente
tunecino decidió atacar de esta manera a
los migrantes subsaharianos
francamente No sabría decirle
exactamente Por qué es cierto que ha
aumentado la presencia de los migrantes
en mi opinión Hay un problema a nivel de
las fronteras tunecinas que no están muy
bien vigiladas en el lado argelino hay
un flujo ciertamente es verdad de gente
pero no hubo mendicidad en las calles se
ve de vez en cuando pero muy raramente
no había violencia No vi ningún tipo de
violencia y recorro las calles de túnez
y voy al sur del país no hay violencia
por parte de esta gente pero no sé la
unión africana emitió un comunicado para
condenar las declaraciones del
presidente y pidió a sus estados
miembros que se abstengan de cualquier
discurso racista le parece suficiente
señalo que al igual que el presidente de
la república tunestina señaló con el
dedo a los subsaharianos yo digo que la
unión africana no ha hecho su trabajo
hasta ahora no ha protegido a sus hijos
no ha buscado saber cómo viven sus hijos
en el Continente están en su continente
no están en otra parte Así que hoy no es
suficiente creo que debería haber un
comité para reflexionar sobre lo que se
debe hacer no no hay que sacar
seriamente una tarjeta roja atunes por
este comportamiento
creo que es importante Añadir que la
sociedad tunecina está un poco dividida
en dos y el foro tunecino por los
derechos económicos y sociales lanzó una
marcha Llamando a los tunecinos Libres a
salir y a decir no al fascismo es muy
interesante decir esto porque este foro
está formado tanto por asociaciones como
por gente muy joven que para mí son los
que tomarán las decisiones de mañana
Gracias por responder a nuestras
preguntas Seguiremos de cerca la
evolución de la situación en túnez
cambiamos de tema fue un gran final para
el ciclista ajeno
vencedor del tour de ciclismo de Ruanda
tras una dura semana de competición y
una clasificación general muy apretada
el corredor de 23 años que ya es dos
veces campeón de África volvió a
triunfar nuestra corresponsal en chigali
Marian condena nos informa esta edición
del tour de Irlanda marca la vuelta de
las etapas normales Después de tres años
de cambios debido a la pandemia un
factor que sin duda complicó estatuto
para muchos corredores Empezando por los
holandeses hubo dos personas que
abandonaron en el equipo Nacional del
país el único corredor que está con
buenos resultados
que es parte de un equipo profesional de
Alemania
cuando siete días fueron buenos pero el
último día no tuve suerte Así que estoy
triste pero la próxima vez espero
hacerlo mejor
en general el Tour fue difícil para
muchos equipos con más de 30 corredores
de que abandonaron incluso los grandes
nombres como Chris from cuatro veces
ganador del Tour de Francia tuvieron
dificultades para desmarcarse con malos
resultados la sorpresa general fue el
gran favorito de esta de este tour que
es un joven eritreo de 22 años en dos
veces campeón de África de ciclismo y
ahora campeón del tour de Irlanda
tuve muchas dificultades en los dos
últimos kilómetros y equipo me dijo que
guardara la calma y que se llegan
llegamos metros
eritrea es conocida por ser una tierra
de campeones de ciclismo Ya el año
pasado fue en eritreo que ganó el Tour
de Irlanda este año son 95 corredores de
20 países del mundo que participaron en
este competición que es una de las más
importantes del ciclismo en África
así cerramos esta edición de África 7
días Gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional sigue en France
[Música]